As part of the experts and emotion interview series,
we will be talking with Dr Yulia Chance Sova Dutton who will share her
experience on whether emotions indeed are socially constructed.
Dr. Chen Sova Dutton received her phd from Stanford University and is currently
an assistant professor at Georgetown.
Her Research Interests Center on cultural shaping of emotions and social support
and she conducts exciting work on emotion and culture internationally and East
Asian,
uh,
Russian and west African cultural context.
So I now turn to a very special experts in emotion interview with a treasured
colleague of mine,
Dr Yulia and Sova Dutton.
Welcome Yulia.
Thank you for speaking with us today.
Thank you.
It's always nice to talk to you.
Um,
I wanted to just start out by asking you a little bit as an expert in emotion.
what first got you interested in emotion?
Well,
I grew up as a daughter of an astronomer on an astrophysical observatory.
So among the natural scientists and fairly early on in my teenage years,
I became interested in the idea that even in case of this very carefully
controlled scientific observations,
um,
our emotions,
motivation,
thoughts are always this unseen,
unacknowledged lens between us and reality.
And I would wonder,
looking at my father and his colleagues getting ready for a observing stars all
night,
how their mood at the time might influence how they pay attention,
whether or not they're going to have particularly useful intuitions later that
day.
And from then on,
once they moved to the United States,
I became increasingly interested in how different cultural contexts shape this
process is shape our motions.
So,
I mean,
really,
it's interesting to hear that because you now are one of the foremost experts on
culture and emotion.
Um,
and so I want to ask you some questions about your work in this domain.
I mean,
you're widely known for your influential role in trying to understand how
different social and you know,
situational factors shape the physiological,
behavioral,
and expressive facets of emotion responding in.
And like you're saying how this various cross culturally.
So I wondered if you could tell us a little bit about this work and to what
extent it might suggest that our emotions are,
you know,
evolutionarily,
sort of hardwired versus more culturally shaped and modified.
I don't necessarily,
uh,
inclusiveness as he worked for,
and this is a very common theme in emotion research to think of emotions as
premiere,
the evolutionarily shaped,
and then culture is sort of icing on the cake if you would,
uh,
writing to the party late in adjusting this responses slightly.
And I think that if you look at,
um,
environments for which humans evolved and was very little in common,
so humans live all over very diverse natural environments and adapt to them
well.
And the common ingredient is that they live with others and they live in a
cultural environment.
So yes,
where the Lucia nearly shaped to deal with natural threats.
I like rapid new responding to snakes or heights or things that might
potentially be polluting dangerous for us,
like something disgusting.
However,
our emotions really are primarily helpful in helping us navigate our cultural
environments.
And so I think emotions evolve to be cultural.
I think,
uh,
preparing us from very early on to take in inputs from our cultural environment
and adjust and number of things about how we behave,
how we pay attention,
how we think,
but also adjust the way in which we experience and express our emotions.
Okay.
So in your,
do you find particular facets of emotion responding more susceptible to cultural
influences than others?
Yes.
So in most of our studies,
what we find when we look at different components of emotion is that when you
look at physiological regenerativity,
uh,
when this team you line that people are responding to artist roughly comparable
and similar in their meaning.
In a particular context,
people show similar physiological reactivity.
So for example,
if you show participants something scary,
their heart rate goes up across cultural context.
We also see considerable similarity and facial expressions.
So people tend to show similar,
uh,
facial expression.
So for example,
smiling when they're feeling positive emotions across context,
even though the intensity and the way that they express a particular expression
are going to differ by context.
But there's similarities there as well.
And then when we move into the domain of the way people think about their
emotions,
um,
uh,
how intensely and how frequently they experienced them,
what they believe about outcomes of their motions,
and also how they respond to situational cues that are all around them.
To what extent these cues churn emotions on or off a or remind people to control
the expressions.
They are,
we see much,
uh,
any many,
many more differences.
So one of the things I love most about your work is you've really provided this
elegant and novel way of,
you know,
thinking about these,
culturally informed models in both positive and negative emotions.
And you've drawn from a wide range of cultural contexts including East Asian,
west African,
and also Russian contacts.
And I've wondered if you could tell us a bit more about some of the most
exciting findings that have emerged by studying emotional systems and these very
different culturally distinct context.
Um,
in Q and.
A.
So when we are looking at different contexts,
we are starting with the culture.
You're drilling and we're trying to understand what are the cultural beliefs and
different cultures drive attention to different aspects of emotion.
So for example,
in East Asian cultural context,
what we see is that emotions are much more likely to be connected to social
environment.
So when European Americans think of their emotions,
they think of internal processes that they get to express.
But I fundamentally within them,
um,
east Asians often think of emotions as literally unfolding and interpersonal
environment.
And as a result would with dental laboratory.
And it was very exciting for us is using simple thoughts,
either yourself or others changes emotions differently in cultural context.
So for example,
and we are proud of myself if I'm European American intensifies emotional
response.
For East Asians,
it doesn't have the same ethic.
But instead thinking about a family member,
someone who has close connection,
do you thinking about relationship primes,
emotions and intensifies them in other contexts.
Other aspects of emotions are culturally salient.
So in is a African context of Ghana.
My colleague Vivian within [inaudible] and I have done the work on the way in
which this context directs attention to the body.
To encourage,
encourages people to attend to how their body is responding.
And we have looked at how this increased enhanced cultural attention to the body
shapes,
emotional response.
And finally,
with my native culture of Russia,
the work that we have done,
they are most recently focuses on Russian beliefs about negative emotions.
And the idea that negative emotions can have very important positive functions
in one's life.
And the way in which these beliefs promote Russian participants to seek negative
emotions even though they're unpleasant for all of us.
Um,
so,
um,
our work in the focus of the work depends to some extent on the context and the
common thread there I would say is that cultures,
providers with the scripts of what emotions are,
how they're supposed to unfold,
um,
wolf in the moment.
And also what are some of the longer range consequences of these emotions.
And when people feel normally different motions,
they don't always follow the same script cause there is this common shared
script,
but we don't all follow it.
Uh,
some of us are better at it than others.
Some of us fled out,
attempt to reject it.
And think of ourselves as not very culturally normative,
but it is impossible to be in a cultural context and not be informed by those
scripts,
not express and experience emotions in reference to those common and stood
scripts.
And so the script's might be about different aspects of emotion in different
contexts,
but our larger project is understanding how these cultural scripts interact with
individual experience and expression.
So fascinating.
I mean,
I love the work you do,
especially just all the different contexts that you sample from to really get a
sense of the wide diversity and emotional response systems across the world.
Um,
one question that came up while you were talking,
I was thinking about is just what you see as some of the most exciting next
steps we can try to pursue if we're interested in trying to understand,
you know,
the role that context has on our emotion,
experience and expression.
I think it becomes increasingly important for us if we take your safety
seriously to introduce contexts in the laboratory.
And what I noticed about,
uh,
much of research comparing particularly European American and Asian,
there is a long tradition for comparing this grips is what we see is that Asian
American participants are,
Asian participants in this study are less emotionally expressive and report
experiencing emotions less intensely when thought all of these studies were
conducted in the laboratory where the person is by themself,
friends are not,
their family members are not there.
There's nobody for them to interact with.
And we think that in an effort to make us that is more controlled.
This is a good idea.
But in essence we are making,
we're stripping away what makes emotions,
emotions for this context.
And so we need to get better at tapping into traditions in our field of how we
can,
um,
continue being very careful and scientific about studying emotion but also
allowing context.
And so currently in my study for example,
I'm doing more work with diets where groups of friends come in and talk about
distressing experiences and observing how cues from one person influenced
emotional reactivity and another person.
And I think that would be a way for us to,
um,
understand context better.
What exciting directions.
I can't wait to hear where it leads you because I think you're right.
You can't study the context and culture without having a real ecologically valid
context.
The person's in in the first place.
They're also readable evolving methods of helping us study emotions right out
there in the world as they unfold either by observing emotions of others.
So for example,
going out there to compare comparable context,
let's say restaurants in Moscow,
Washington,
um,
uh,
Tokyo and observing how people show their emotions when they're talking to close
to others.
Um,
or just having people carry,
that's a me versus devices and examining what they feel in their daily as you do
so well in,
in your own work.
Oh,
you do the interesting RightCare,
Yulia,
and I'm your biggest fan.
Um,
one of the last things I want to ask you about that I think is really striking
too is you not only look at these cross cultural models of emotion,
you know,
around the world,
but you also have this really important translational component where you look
at cultural variation and emotional responding among individuals diagnosed with
depression,
one of the most common severe and debilitating of all emotional disorders.
And I just wonder your perspective.
You know,
to what extent cultural contexts serves as either a potential buffer against or
a risk factor for,
you know,
the onset or severity of disorders like depression?
I think cultural context can serve as a buffer in a number of different ways and
we can consider all different influences starting with,
um,
you know,
genetic vulnerabilities in a particular population.
Um,
the extent to which particular types of stressors are presented,
how people characteristic with cope with the stressors would kind of support
systems are the,
uh,
and,
and I'm also very interested in how cultural context,
um,
I think expressions of disorder because to the extent that we have this
normative scripts for how to feel and express our emotions,
depression seems to not just affect our emotional experiences in a vacuum,
but affects how well we interact with this scripts.
I,
so in some of our studies we find that,
uh,
depression appears to potentially interrupt people's ability to follow scripts
resulting in,
um,
the pattern golf people doing,
going to culture,
counter culture,
uh,
emotional expression and experience.
Um,
and,
uh,
as a result,
you see very interesting patterns where,
for example,
in Asian American cultural context,
depression is associated not with the implant but with enhanced emotional
reactivity.
Whereas in European American context,
we see more damp in emotional community in response to the norm express openly
Asian contexts in response to the norm to typically moderate.
So I think when we are thinking about assessment and treatment,
it's important for clinician to do assessment of individuals emotional
functioning,
but also to do some degree of assessment for what cultural norms this is
individual interacting with it,
living with.
And again,
with the idea that of course everybody in the context is going to be different.
There's tremendous we can cultural variability and that's the norm.
Um,
but even the person who doesn't follow their cultural norm is responding to that
norm in some way.
And clinician needs to know about it.
So we,
um,
study how person is functioning.
We scanned their brains and as cultural circle just Hazel Markus is fond of
Samuelson,
you just scan the cultural environment.
I stand psychological functioning better.
So how do you think we might be able to use these findings Sunday to develop
more culturally sensitive or tailored psychological interventions when,
you know,
really trying to combat emotional related difficulties and depression for
example.
Clinicians just need to be aware and it,
the norms differ and keep it in their mind as a possibility of what they need to
ask about.
So,
for example,
in our studies we show that,
um,
when we compare healthy and depressed European American and Asian American
individuals,
uh,
depressed European American individuals in their emotional reactivity are
virtually indistinguishable from non-depressed healthy Asian Americans and who
clinician easy mistake to make.
So interacting with a person who is highly oriented to East Asian culture to
take very culturally normative way of moderating one's IX emotional expression
based on relational context,
to take it as an indication that the person doesn't feel intensely and this is
potentially problematic.
So,
um,
as part of assessment,
clinicians need to have skills to,
to,
to ask good questions about this.
And we wouldn't ever expect clinicians to know about every culture in the world.
That's not realistic of course,
but they need to assess it.
And then treatment,
we also need to think about what are our goals.
So if a typical,
let's say Russian firmly believes that sadness is an important part of one's
life and wants to cultivate it in themselves and their family members and their
children.
Even if this ration is depressed,
what is our goal for their sadness?
Obviously we don't want them to be in beard.
We want them to be functionally well,
but I want them to be functioning well in their context.
We don't want to eliminate the sadness entirely.
The want to leave this cultural benefits of sadness probably in place.
So our goals for treatment might differ with me.
Help a person do well in their context.
Then relative to some universal standard or for the emotional functioning might
look like.
So you as an expert and emotion,
where do you see the future of this field headed?
I think we're in a really exciting point in our field right now and in part what
I really like about it is that we're gaining a really good understanding now of
the way in which emotions are these emergent properties.
All of our physiology of our mind and of our culture.
And I think we're very to being able to create programs of research that take
all these components into account to try to understand how our neurons at
training by our cultures and vice versa.
Because this is a by directional influenced how what we bring to the table is
humans shapes our countries over time.
Um,
so I see a lot of possibilities in this program of research.
And so when students come to you,
um,
and they are sort of thinking about embarking in this field of emotion,
looking ahead,
what,
what might line store for them,
what kind of advice do you give students?
I told them that they are in a field that is rapidly developing.
Even in just the few years that I've been around,
is there any researcher,
so much information,
new information becomes available to us.
So I told them that they should be prepared to be absorbing new information very
rapidly.
They need to have a high degree of,
uh,
uncertain tolerance because in our field we are still trying to come up with a
basic definitions.
We're still not in agreement about what emotion is.
Your hands are difficult to manage.
Uh,
um,
not having that certainty,
but,
uh,
in my mind this is a really wonderful thing about her,
I feel because we get to argue about this very important,
interesting ideas.
I would also tell them it given the fact that cultural psychologist of emotion
should be prepared to,
to,
to think about the ways in which brain and culture interact with each other.
That they should be thinking about training in very kind of tangible skills such
as physiological reactivity,
no rest science,
genetic contributions to emotions.
And simultaneously they need to be thinking very carefully about how we
understand cultural norms,
values,
and beliefs about emotion.
How do we study those beyond very broad distinction such as individuals and
collectivism?
More specifically in this context,
um,
what do people think about emotions?
What are the common scripts for how emotions are expressed in healthy and let's
see,
depressed individuals.
And so can you share students of emotions have a lot of training to,
to if they are going to be serious about capturing,
uh,
both of those demands or at least knowing you now for both those domains in
order to join this interdisciplinary teams of researchers.
So a lot of exciting times ahead with diverse approaches and tools.
Absolutely.
Well,
thank you so much for speaking today.
You,
Elliot was always,
and it is always a pleasure to speak with you.
Thank you so much for inviting me.
So this concludes our experts in emotion interview with Doctor Yulia Chance Sova
Dutton from Georgetown University.